late night shows they feature
celebrities having fun you know playing
games singing karaoke putting on funny
wigs and it's all good fun yeah yeah
humanizes them humanizes him and it's
all good time and you know I thought we
got to get in on that yeah you know cuz
I'm just always trying to depress people
and I thought I want in on that having
fun thing so here we go check it out
ladies and gentlemen we got some of the
biggest celebrities in Hollywood to
battle head-to-head in a no-holds-barred
dance competition yeah you will not
believe the stars that came out for this
that's right ladies and gentlemen it's
time for the conan mega celebrity dance
off challenge idris elba - Ayoka
vertical glowing Kate Winslet famous for
her movie performance in Titanic she is
really moving on that dance floor and
hey check it out she ends with a frizzy
fries bonus points - Kate Winslet let's
see a dress Elba beat that but first a
quick word about our dance-off challenge
sponsor Falcon ID drones all Falcon
height drones feature military-grade
whip live construction and patented
tungsten reinforced flap choice now back
to the action
a Juris Alva look at him he looks sexy
he has the moves to back it up there's a
combo and a super toggle incredible
let's see an instant replay instant
replay here pretty amazing again all
that footage was captured by Falcon I
the top choice in ultra vertical
cinematography back to the dance-off
this is incredible Kate Winslet is
having some help from Jonah Hill Joseph
gordon-levitt and Academy Award winner
Sam Rockwell
amazing let's get in for a much closer
look and test the Falcon eye drones
powerful zoom lens and another great
feature its predator vision thermal
imaging sensor man Jody Hill is going
nice yes thank you to our celebrities
Kate Winslet eat yourself a Tony Hill
Joseph gordon-levitt and Sam Rockwell
challenge
internet's gonna blow up when the ad